in many videos already we have talked
about our three branches of government
in the United States but what we're
going to do in this videos focus a
little bit more on the judicial branch
as we've talked about judicial branches
main goal is to be the final authority
on the United States Constitution and
the main check that they have on the
legislative and executive branches is
that they can deem things that are
happening in the other branches say a
law that gets passed by Congress or an
executive order from the president as
being unconstitutional they can also
interpret the laws that have been passed
and so that's where they get their power
now another interesting thing about the
judicial branch that we've talked about
is unlike the executive and legislative
branch where these folks are elected in
a semi-regular basis the Supreme Court
these are lifetime appointments once
someone is nominated by a president and
then confirmed by the Senate they're in
the Supreme Court for life and so the
question is is when the Supreme Court
does something that say the president or
a member of Congress disagrees with what
can they do well there's a couple of
options here one option let's say that a
clause of a law is deemed
unconstitutional so let's say that
there's a law here and this part of it
the US Supreme Court says now that's not
consistent with the Constitution
sometimes the legislature might decide
to hey let's try to pass another law
that clarifies that clause in a in a way
that is in line with the Constitution or
will do a whole other law that's worded
different but it has the same purpose
and so the legislative branch can't
overrule the judicial branch but they
can try to revise their laws to get more
in line with their intent but not get
the negative judicial review the
president also has some levers there's
examples in history of the president
just outright ignoring a judicial
verdict for example Thomas Jefferson
during the embargo acts during his
administration this is during the
Napoleonic Wars and those warring
nations were taking advantage of
American vessels and seamen and Thomas
Jefferson decided he
we don't want to have trade with those
countries there are aspects of those
that the supreme court including some
Jefferson appointees decide were
unconstitutional but Jefferson just kind
of kept executing the way he wanted to
you fast forward a few decades to the
beginning of the Civil War President
Lincoln decided that hey there's some
people causing some trouble and we need
to detain them and we know there's a
constitutional right of habeas corpus
that says that people should be allowed
to go to court to decide whether the
detention is legal to decide whether
they should be detained but President
Lincoln decided to suspend habeas corpus
in certain parts of the country which
the Supreme Court was not happy with but
he decided to just go ahead with it with
the argument that it was necessary to
preserve the Union and perhaps the most
famous example of a president not being
happy with verdicts of the Supreme Court
was FDR as he took office in the midst
of the Great Depression there's a whole
series of federal programs that he was
trying to pass and the Supreme Court
started to strike down many of these
saying that hey this was not the role of
the federal government or this was
overreaching by the executive and so FDR
was not happy with this and so he
actually proposed to the legislative
branch the judicial procedures reform
bill of 1937 which essentially said hey
as soon as the Supreme Court justice is
over seventy and a half years old I
should be able to appoint another
Supreme Court justice up to six and it
turns out that their works exactly six
justices who had already reached that
age and so he essentially wanted to pack
the Supreme Court with six new justices
that would agree with him that would
allow him to do what he wanted the
legislative branch did not pass his
judicial procedures reform bill of 1937
but some historians think that it had
the impact that he wanted because it
seems that we don't know for sure that
after he even tried to do this the
judicial branch seemed more friendly to
FDR so maybe they said hey you know
maybe we don't want to mess with this
guy too much because eventually he might
be successful instead of having nine
Supreme Court justices we'll have 15
people sometimes call this the switch in
that saved 9 but to get an appreciation
of how people thought about it I have
some political cartoons from the time
and these are fun to just pause and take
a look at so this is trying to change
the umpiring so this is a Supreme Court
President Roosevelt the heir and he's
saying listen I don't like your
decisions from now on you're going to
have to work with someone who can see
things my way
and you can see all the different bats
that he tried to use and they were all
ruled out by the umpire the NRA the AAA
these are all different government
institutions or programs that FDR was
trying to set up in order to fight the
Great Depression as part of his New Deal
and they say New Deal acts declared
unconstitutional I have another
political cartoon right over here and
it's from that same period in time do we
want a ventriloquist act in the Supreme
Court and you see Uncle Sam here and
then you have FDR and it looks like he's
got his hand controlling these puppets
and says yes yes we all vote yes
even though FDR did not get his way with
his court packing plan as it's sometimes
called let me write that down
his court packing plan as I mentioned
some historians believe that it did help
influence the court being a little bit
friendlier to him and as somewhat irony
of it is at the end of the day because
FDR served so many terms in office he
was able to make 8 out of 9 Supreme
Court appointments so in a lot of ways
he did determine the inclinations of the
Supreme Court for many decades to come
well after his administration